you hungry little
[Music]
guy
oh
oh hi there little
[Music]
buddy you hungry little guy
you want a little
[Music]
more and that's how I adopted
John okay now have you ever with
a please no it's so hot it's hurting ow
ow ow you deserve to be seen when
somebody has
say when never John bury me and cheese
oh I apologize in advance the eating
you're about to see will not be pretty
and if you have young children this
would be a good time for them to leave
the room you never
nobody hey jior this is fck my father
you everever jump a train I've never
jumped here's that stop really
where
a oh OD you think he'd see that coming
let's get it I deserve to be with
somebody
me wait for
it
it's somebody
this
[Music]
color me intrigued